[Music]
here on the Ingraham angle we bring you
stories that no one else is covering
because it's important for you to know
exactly what's going on in our country
now earlier this week we told you about
the hundreds of Congolese migrants who
entered our country via the southern
border being dumped into San Antonio
my next guest investigative journalist
or is Gary ger went there to get the
real story for himself and he's here
with exclusive recordings and
information for us ORS you asked one of
the migrants how they got here and this
is what she said let's watch
they seem very reluctant to give you
information tell us about it
yes I approached him in a pretty chaotic
scene on the sidewalk and then I asked
him where they from and with how they
came here and I said Ecuador and it took
a while that they I'm you know we're a
little bit warmed up and when they
realized that I was asking about money
and about who brought them here they
were backpacking so they were not they
were not answering at all and when I
came back a few minutes later and you
speak French Swiss so he speaks German
French and English show off so you speak
French so it was easy for you to
communicate with them and you said that
there are very few translators so the 30
or so people that are outside the
shelter oh you were able to speak to
some of them yes yes and there were
really a lack of times I think there was
one other person there who worked
officially so I asked him and they
wouldn't tell me anything about how they
got here and then they started to get
aggressive and they were contradicting
each other they one said they went
through the forest and the other one
said no there was no forest so and they
were actually arguing among themselves
and when it came to money and help
that's when they started to get
aggressive well I want to play some more
of this here's one of the migrants
telling you about her journey
[Music]
no no they don't want to tell you why
the secrecy about how they got here but
then people are concerned you can
probably know because there's been
another outbreak fairly serious of Ebola
in the Congo
now there's a law 21-day incubation
period so the sense is they couldn't be
bringing it here but still people want
to be sure so that's why the questions
are really important yes that that might
be one one side but the other thing is I
had the impression that somebody told
them not to speak about it and when they
said we're here now in the States
why do you ask about our past and then
came a very aggressive kind of claim
give me help now we hear you have to
help us give us money who's funding
these migrants I mean it was I couldn't
get deeper than there than this but what
I found out is through an aid work there
he said they actually do have money
quite a few of them because he spotted
them under a tree right in front of the
shelter counting there a roll of money
with hundred-dollar bills and he spotted
them and they just put it back in the
pocket he didn't take it away of them of
course but they still hanging there and
waiting for you know public help
where did they expect to be going did
they have friends or family here they
want to go there with the ones there's
about three dozens left now of that 250
group and they won't all want to go to
Portland Maine like the Congo and other
African countries are being basically
they're repopulating Portland Maine with
a huge contingent of these immigrants
these migrants and it's it's
overwhelming the Maine authorities I
mean they're pretty liberal up there
they're like we can't take any more
people were full up but they're there
they're hoping to go there they're
hoping and they told the Congo there and
they're told that I was told there's no
solution anytime soon for them all right
and you also found a document that a
group called races has been handing out
to the migrants in
we're familiar with this group but this
is what it looks like tell us about what
this document says a particularly
disturbing part of it we put up on
screen yeah so they're handing that out
it's in French
yep they're handing that out to the to
the migrants and dairy I'm telling them
their rights and when it comes to ice it
says ice is government they are not your
friends and as a Swiss I think you know
what's this kind of information and they
you flip the page then it comes again
with ice and says ice is kind of police
they are not friendly don't ever tell
them anything confidential so this is
outrageous so this is a NGO
non-governmental organisation assisting
aid workers telling the migrants who are
going to get money from the US taxpayers
not to cooperate with the government ORS
thank you for going down there all the
way from Switzerland we really
appreciate your help tonight
understanding this story